In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 15th, on which we commemorate St. Augustine of
Hippo, his feast day is the 28th of August in the Latin Church, urged by both his intellectual
formation and the circumstances of his conversion to envisage the relationship of man with God,
from a more or less psychological point of view, differing from that adopted by earlier
patristic tradition, St. Augustine gave all his theology a personal aspect, which influenced
his doctrine of the Holy Trinity, original sin, the relationship between nature and grace,
etc.
As long as these theses were considered to be personal theological opinions, their logumina,
they were no impediment to the veneration of Augustine in the ranks of Orthodox saints.
It was only when they were adopted as the official and exclusive doctrine of the Roman church,
notably the Filioque, that they became the main subject of dissension between the two churches.
If one can rightly venerate St. Augustine as an Orthodox saint, it is less for his qualities
as a theologian than as pastor and for his undeniable personal sanctity.
David Fotius wrote about him, knowing that some of the fathers and doctors have deviated
from the faith in certain dogmas, we do not receive as doctrine those matters in which they
have deviated, but we no less continue to extend the hand of friendship to those men.
Some people, because of this, give him the title, blessed, or yetos, but such distinctions
being unknown in Orthodox holographic tradition, it is enough here to make this distinction between
his life and the unfortunate development of his doctrine.
In the 18th century St. Demetri of Rostov put his commemoration in his great monology, but
this action drew the wrath of Moscow theologians on him, as they considered that this was a
reversion to the ratification of Latin theology.
The memory of St. Augustine of Hippo, St. Augustine saw the light of day in 354 in Tagast, a town
in Numidia on the border of present-day Algeria and Tunisia.
His father, Atricius, a small landowner who ranked among the eminent men of the town
remained pagan to the end of his days, but his mother, St. Monica, was a fervent Christian
and had him enrolled while still a child among the catacumans, taking him regularly to church
to teach him the mysteries of the faith.
Autism, however, being deferred according to the custom of the time, the child showed
himself unmanageable and rebellious against his mother's remonstrances and turned his back
on the faith.
Endowed with brilliant intelligence, he quickly acquired great ease in the Latin language,
but was recalcitrant over learning Greek, which remained a gap in his theological thinking.
At the age of seventeen, he was sent to Carthage, the metropolis of Africa, to take a course
in rhetoric.
The temptations of the city and the bad company he kept led him into a life of debauchery,
and he had a relationship with a Christian woman who gave him a son, Adiodatus in 372.
Thanks to the reading of Cicero, he turned from the vain study of law and rhetoric to seek
truth and wisdom.
Disappointed, though, by the apparent dryness of the Bible, he showed greater sympathy for
the doctrine of the Manikians, which seemed to him to reconcile Christ with his desire to
acquire wisdom through pure reason.
He was to spend nine years in the toils of this heresy, however uncouth it was.
After a brief stay in Tagast, teaching grammar, he left again for Carthage to open a school
of rhetoric there.
The bad behavior of his students, however, very quickly disgusted him with the profession.
Having lost his illusions about Manikism after a discussion with Faustos, one of their bishops,
he, his spirit unquiet and avid for true knowledge, set sail for Rome, where he opened
another school and had little greater success.
Healed of a serious illness and having found paid employment as a retarition in Milan, he
went to live there, still nourishing the dream of a brilliant career in administration in 384.
He was presented to the bishop St. Ambrose, who conquered him by his gentleness and kindness,
and above all by his brilliant eloquence and spiritual interpretation of the holy scriptures
which opened his heart to the depths of the Word of God.
Monica, who had joined him, persuaded him to leave his concubine and tried in vain to arrange
an advantageous marriage for him.
Both philosophy and worldly pleasure had so disappointed Augustine that it was with pain
and anguish that he sought the source of true happiness.
The reading of neoplatonic philosophers made him abandon Manikism once and for all, and
freed him to undertake the interior quest of a spiritual life.
In contrast to these philosophies, this interiorization was not for him futile speculative research,
but took the form of an ardent seeking of the God incarnate, whom he admitted with his intellect,
but his heart could not yet experience.
It was then that he heard of the life of St. Anthony the Great, written by St. Athanasius
during his exile in the West, which was bringing about sensational conversions among the nobility.
Shortly afterwards, when he was in his friend Alipios's garden, weeping in solitude about
his life, he heard a child's voice chanting, take and read.
He opened a volume of St. Paul's epistles that was lying there and stopped at the passage.
Put ye on the Lord Jesus Christ and make no provision for the flesh to fulfill the lusts
thereof.
All shadow of doubt disappeared at once, and a gentle light bathed his heart with joy.
At that moment he became a new man, who would thenforth live only for Jesus Christ and his
church.
When he told his mother of this revelation, she exalted with joy.
After having abandoned forever his profession of purveyor of words, he withdrew for several
months with his mother, Kinsfolk, and a few friends to a country estate to recover from
an illness that the emotion of his conversion had aggravated.
In this semi-monastery where he hoped to lead a life similar to that of the apostolic
community in Jerusalem, Augustin linked together prayer, meditation on the scriptures, and
philosophical discussion.
On his return to Milan, he lived an austere and retired life before being baptized by saint
Ambrose on the 24th of April in 387, together with Alepius and his son Adiodatus.
He then went to Ostia with Saint Monica, with the aim of returning to Africa to live the
monastic life there, one evening while they were talking leaning against a window.
They were suddenly carried away by the loftiness of their pious conversation and the aspiration
of their whole hearts to the waters of the heavenly fountain, and found themselves lifted
in a sort of ecstasy up above all creatures, visible and invisible, to enter into communion
with eternal wisdom, an instant of contemplation that seemed to them to be an invitation to taste
eternal life, here below in conformity with the gospel words, enter thou into the joy
of thy Lord.
Saint Monica died shortly afterwards, and Augustin, taking up his project again, stayed in Italy
a while longer to write polemical works against the Manichians.
In September 388, he returned to Tagast, with Alepius and Adiodatus, who were soon taken
by death.
Augustin sold all his possessions and gave the proceeds to the poor, and devoted himself
for three years to the organization of a monastery, together with his friends and disciples.
After fasting and prayer, he joined meditation day and night, on the law of God, and communicated
that which the Lord had given him to understand in conversations with those who were present,
and by letter to those who were not.
When he had gone one day to the little town of Hippo, at the request of an imperial official
who wanted to hear him, in order to decide about whether or not to be converted, Augustin
appeared, with the aged Bishop Valerius in the presence of the people.
When the prelate told them of his desire to make provision for the ordination of a priest
to assist him by preaching in Latin, as he was Greek speaking, the faithful suddenly grabbed
a hold of Augustin, greeting him with a thunderous ovation, and it was with many tears at the danger
presented by the pastoral ministry that he accepted, leaving God for God, that is renouncing
the gentle retreat of the monastery in order to serve the body of Christ.
He obtained, however, a delay of several months to prepare himself for his ministry by meditation
on the Scriptures, and after his ordination the Bishop gave him a plot near the church,
on which to found a new monastery, the monastery of the garden, that gave about ten bishops to
the church.
Towards the end of 395 he received episcopal consecration, and shortly afterwards succeeded
Valerius in the sea of Hippo.
Placed on the throne of his tiny diocese but illuminating the whole of the African church,
on the furthest limits of the Latin world, Saint Augustin was, for 35 years, a model
by his teaching of the good shepherd, giving his life for his sheep, and seeing himself
as the servant of the servants of God.
He preached indefinitely nearly every day, almost 800 of his sermons are being preserved, addressing
every subject with incomparable liveliness and art, and seeking to convey his love of God
and of heavenly blessings to his hearers.
During the day he settled disputes, watching over the church's administration, caring for
the poor, not hesitating to melt down the sacred vessels when the gold ran out, and during
the night became a monk again, entirely consecrated to the love of his spouse.
He lived in his episcopal house in community with his clergy, for whom he wrote a monastic
rule, adapted to their conditions of life but demanding a strict observance of poverty and
the evangelical commandments.
His burning love for the unity of the church did not leave him indifferent to the matters
that were disturbing Christianity.
He took part in councils and shed his radiance over Roman Africa that had, till then, been
cruelly divided, placing all his art and skill at the service of the truth.
He wrote about a hundred works, the greater number of which were devoted to the struggle
against the schismatics, heretics, and pagans.
When first brilliantly refuted the mannequins, he directed his fire on the novations schismatics,
who reckoned to subordinate the validity of the sacraments to the virtue of the ministry,
and who had, for almost a century, been sowing disastrous dissensions in the African church
by creating a parallel hierarchy there.
When all the holy bishops' efforts and arguments to bring them back to the bosom of the church,
it hurled themselves fruitlessly against their obstinate hatred.
It was with a heavy heart that he resolved to appeal to the secular powers, though without
ever justifying the acts of violence.
As there were many who considered the Christians responsible for the fall of Rome in 410, Augustin
wrote a great work, The City of God, a vast reflection on human history in which he shows that
the church, passing through its vicissitudes, is moving towards the eternal kingdom.
After this, it was against the pelagian heresy, a heresy that diminished the role of divine
grace and considered that man by his own strength was able to sin no more, also denying the
transmission of original sin and stating that it was useless to baptize children, that
he had to do battle.
Augustin strove to overturn this doctrine in order to protect the faith of the church, but
influenced by the demands of the controversy and by his spirit that was avid for rational
clarifications.
This controversy had scarcely any echo in the east, as the Greek fathers, who were mostly
unaware of Augustin, conceived of this relationship between nature and grace as cooperation
in the past.
Sinidia, Augustin's desire to probe too deeply into the mystery of divine prescience, led him
to an exaggerated conception of predestination that kept an orthodox sense to the extent to
which it is understood that it was the consequences of free acts, foreseen from all eternity by
the creator, but not determined by him.
His doctrine was, however, the source of various Western heresies concerning predestination,
such as Calvinism.
Strove to overturn this doctrine in order to protect the faith of the church, but influenced
by the demands of the controversy and by his spirit that was avid for rational clarification,
he established too strict an opposition between nature and grace that later had damaging consequences
in the west.
He succeeded in having the pelagians condemned by the councils of Carthage in 411 and Rome
in 417, but the heresy persisted when the vandals from Spain began to invade Christian
Africa, destroying everything in their path, the Holy Bishop worked unstintingly to save
whatever could be saved.
After 40 years of episcopate and apostolic labor, he saw with great sadness, idolatry reborn
in the midst of the blood-spattered ruins and the area in heresy imposed by the conquerors.
Hippo was besieged for three months during which he was seized by a violent fever.
He had the penitential psalms written large and hung on the walls of his room, and it was
with the fervor of a new convert that he gave his valorous soul into the Lord's hands on
the 28th of August in 427.
If Saint Augustine's doctrine gave the opportunity for deviations in the medieval west, he
cannot nevertheless be charged with heresy.
He always humbly submitted his reflections to the judgment of the church and, ending his
de trinitate, he wrote,
O Lord God, the One God, God the Trinity, whatever I have said in these books, that is
of thine, may they acknowledge who are thine.
If there is anything of my own, may it be pardoned, both by thee and by those who are thine.
Amen.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.